[Musik]
mich ärgert wenn fahrlässig umgegangen
wird mit den regeln ich würde auf jeden
fall wird es angebote schaffen weil ich
glaube das wichtigste in diesen zeiten
ich würde mir wünschen dass so die
auseinandersetzung innerhalb der
gesellschaft nicht so sind also ich
finde diesen hass gegen ungeimpfte wie
finde ich ganz furchtbar ist schon nicht
schön man hat sich weihnachten anders
vorgestellt wir können damit nicht leben
das haben wir noch nicht begriffen was
machen wir mehr machen müssen zumal
jetzt in afrika noch mehr dazu gekommen
ist dass wir haben auch bald hier haben
ja stimmen und stimmungen von der straße
heute und egal ob der imker ungeimpfte
co und abhandeln sie beschäftigt die
herzen und köpfe der deutschen genauso
intensiv wie es in der ersten welle der
fall gewesen ist und damit gute namen zu
diesem zdf spezial betis diagnose
verschiebt sich um circa 15 minuten die
zahl der korona neuinfektionen heute
also so hoch wie nie seit beginn dieser
krise und was machen diejenigen die
etwas dagegen tun könnten sie mahnen sie
rufen wie entspannte heute davon spricht
es sei nicht mehr fünf nach zwölf
sondern bereits halb eins allein seine
minister tage sind gezählt bald sitzen
andere am kabinettstisch reicht das was
die ampel der vierten welle
entgegensetzen will zumal jetzt auch
noch eine neue variante auftaucht bevor
wir darüber sprechen schaut cornelia
donath auf die fallzahlen und die
eigenschaft die sie so bedrohlich macht
wenn die korona zahlen exponentiell
wachsen bedeutet das dass sie sich
innerhalb eines festen zeitraums
verdoppeln derzeit sind das rund 28 tage
der exponentielle anstieg verläuft aber
nicht gleichmäßig er wird durch
verschiedene faktoren beeinflusst durch
harte maßnahmen etwa konnte das
exponentielle wachstum in der ersten
welle früh gestoppt werden in der
zweiten ab oktober 20 gelang das bereits
deutlich schlechter hier lag der
höchststand der neuinfektionen an
heiligabend bei mehr als 1 30.000 die
dritte welle konnte am 23 april
gebrochen werden bei gut 29.000 fällen
in der aktuellen welle explodieren die
zahlen und liegen heute bei mehr als
76.000 bis ende des jahres könnten sich
wenn sich nichts ändert mehr als 140.000
menschen anstecken täglich auch eine
hohe impfquote kann die ausbreitung des
virus verlangsamen dann verlängert sich
die verdopplung zeit das exponentielle
wachstum nimmt ab
ja eine lage die wir mit karl lauterbach
besprechen wollen guten abend nach köln
aber wenn wir uns einen hauch hoffnung
einflößen wollten was muss jetzt
passieren aus ihrer sicht um die wucht
der vierten welle doch noch zu brechen
oder ist es dafür längst zu spät
wir werden die vierte wäre brechen
allerdings wir müssen die booster
impfung massiv beschleunigen ist es
wirklich sehr schnell geimpft werden wir
müssen die kontakt beschränkungen viel
besser kontrollieren also zweig und 2g
plus muss kontrolliert werden also es
muss auch zu entsprechenden sanktionen
kommen und die wären die kontakte aus
werten also werden wir die kontakte
nicht stärker runter bekommen als wir
bisher sehen hört man möglicherweise
auch noch einmal nach schärfen müssen
ihre parteichefin saskia esken setzt ja
auch auf booster sie setzt auf zweig und
2g plus und auch kontakt beschränkungen
wie sie sagen aber fresken will keinen
lockdown für geimpfte gehen sie damit
naja ob wir nochmal einen lock down für
geimpfte brauchen das bezweifle ich auch
denn also welchen sinn hätte die impfung
wenn man dann doch in den lock down muss
sehr viel entscheidender ist dass wir
diejenigen jetzt erreichen die noch
umgehend sind sehr entscheidend ist auch
dass diejenigen nochmal empfinde ich
schon geimpft sind die booster impfungen
und wir müssen schauen dass wir die
großen veranstaltung runter bekommen
denn die sind tatsächlich für die
infektion von bedeutung also hier kann
also wahrscheinlich also noch andere
nach schaffen aber wir haben gute
beschlüsse gefasst wir sehen auch schon
wirkung die wirkung ist aber nicht so
stark wie also notwendig es muss
möglicherweise noch einmal nachgelegt
die ampel parteien die wollen aber nicht
nachlegen die wollen jetzt erstmal das
infektionsgeschehen zehn tage beobachten
zumindest sagt das annalena baerbock
sehen ob und wie booster impfungen und
die neuen maßnahmen an schlagen haben
wir denn in der jetzigen lage wirklich
so viel zeit
also jetzt die lage zu beobachten das
ist natürlich notwendig war die also
maßnahmen wirken der seit ein paar tagen
aber man muss jeden tag schauen das
machen wir auch also die daten werden
noch tagesaktuell erhoben jeden tag
bekommen wir neue bewegungsprofile
beispielsweise und somit also können wir
das schon einschätzen die ampel wird das
gut lösen also wir sind dann täglichen
austausch übrigens auch mit der noch
amtierenden regierung zum beispiel bin
ich auch ein austausch mit jens spahn
und mit so mit anderen also wir sind im
guten austausch wir kriegen das problem
in den griff aber es ist schwerer als
gedacht wir sind dann noch zu spät
eingestiegen und sind ein paar wochen
verloren gegangen wo wir früher mit 2g
und zwei gibt es schon nicht mehr
frieren müssen immerhin zieht ja die
impfkampagne jetzt deutlich an aber die
hausärzte die bekommen nächste woche
wohl nur die hälfte der bestellten
impfstoffe zum teil weniger als die
eigentlich garantierten 30 dosen pro
woche wird die wachsende
impfbereitschaft so nicht gleich wieder
abgewürgt
dieses problem muss auch gelöst wenn wir
sagen wir die gute nachricht dass
moderner der impfstoff der genauso gut
ist wie bei antec also in kaum
begrenzter zahl zur verfügung steht das
heißt also hier kann jeder geimpft
werden da gibt werden möchte wenn auch
bereit ist moderner zu nehmen die sind
sehr sehr guten dem stoff und zum
zweiten also wenn tatsächlich hier also
etwas weniger bei und acht zur verfügung
steht dann liegt das auch daran dass
gott sei dank die zahl der ärzte die
impfen wollen viel größer ist als
berechnet wurde also das
bundesgesundheitsministerium land ja
diese 30.000 pro arzt berechnet und
jetzt sind aber sehr viel mehr ärzte
bereit zu impfen gute nachricht sagte
spd-gesundheitsexperte karl lauterbach
ob ja auch der neue
bundesgesundheitsminister gesprochen hat
die frage können wir heute abend leider
nicht klären für köln
ich danke ihnen und es gibt noch mehr
fragen und zwar an eine partei die
künftig mit der spd zusammen regiert und
regieren das heißt in den nächsten
wochen ja vor allem eine krise
historischen ausmaßes meistern zu müssen
in erlangen begrüße ich den fdp-
fraktionsvize michael theurer guten
abend
guten abend ich grüße sie herr teurer
mehr als
76.000 neue positivtests jeden tag
hunderte tote aber die fdp schließt eine
impfpflicht weiterhin aus wie lange noch
wir prüfen ja gerade derzeit sehr
intensiv die einführung einer
impfnachweis pflicht für einrichtungen
also für hochrisiko bereich und in
seinem guten gesprächen mit unseren
koalitionspartnern und was wir jetzt
sehen sind ja infektionen die zwei
wochen zurückliegen kann da unterbrach
hat sie gerade angesprochen es war ein
fataler fehler von
bundesgesundheitsminister schlagen die
bürger tags die christen größen
abzuschaffen werden das immer
kritisieren auch gewand wieder
abschaffung der bürger tests anfang
oktober geht ein starker anstieg des r
wertes und jetzt haben wir ja sehr
weitgehende maßnahmen beschlossen die
wirken müssen also verschärfungen 3gs
und 3g beim arbeitgeber zwei zweige plus
das sind massive maßnahmen und ja wir
sind für eine nachweispflicht für
risikobereich noch mal zurück zur
allgemeinen pflicht weite teile der
bevölkerung sind da offenbar schon
weiter als sie es gibt ein neues
zdf-politbarometer danach sind mehr als
zwei drittel der deutschen nämlich genau
69 prozent für eine impfpflicht gut ihre
wähler hätten sie damit vielleicht nicht
alle auf ihrer seite aber die leute
schon und darauf sollte es doch eine
regierung ankommen oder
präsident gassen von der
kassenärztlichen bundesvereinigung hat
darauf hingewiesen dass eine allgemeine
impfpflicht aktuell gar nicht helfen
würde weil das hauptproblem im moment
gerade ist impftermine zu bekommen lange
schlangen
im fraktionen schwierigkeiten in der
impfstoffversorgung wir konzentrieren
uns deshalb darauf dass jeder einen
impftermin bekommt ich bin der meinung
es muss ein anspruch also das recht
geben zeitnah geimpft zu werden für
jeden und es zeigt auch dass die
verschärften maßnahmen dazu führen dass
ohne eine allgemeine impfpflicht die
impfbereitschaft nach oben geht aber
wenn wir über eine allgemeine
impfpflicht sprechen gibt es auch da
wieder unterschiede nämlich die
zwangsimpfung die wir ablehnen weil wir
sind mit dem grundgesetz nicht vereinbar
halten es wird aber jetzt mittlerweile
eine schwächere form diskutiert also die
frage eines bußgeldes und sie merkten
daran dass man mit so einer allgemeinen
diskussion der impfpflicht das thema
eben nicht richtig erfasst
entscheidend ist dass mehr menschen sich
impfen lassen ich bin doppelt geimpft
und das mich wenn es irgendwie geht
baldmöglichst postern und unser blick
richtet sich ja vor allen dingen in land
wie israel die es geschafft haben durch
post oder testen ohne eine impfpflicht
die inzidenz auf unter 50 aktuell 33 zu
drücken und die seit drei wochen kein
cola toten meer zu beklagen haben das
wäre jetzt das ziel aber die fdp wird
alle maßnahmen ergreifen die notwendig
sind mit den koalitionspartnern mehrere
bälle zu an diesen worten werden wir sie
messen herr teurer vielen dank für diese
auskünfte nach erlangen
danke ihnen
ja alpha beta gamma delta und nun lehrt
noch eine variante die welt das fürchten
eine mit dem kürzel b115 29 die
weltgesundheitsorganisation hat heute
diese neue variante mit dem namen um die
krone als besorgnis erregend eingestuft
viele länder reagieren und dagmar neue
zeigt wie
schon gestern hatte großbritannien den
flugverkehr aus sechs afrikanischen
ländern eingeschränkt
viele regierungen zogen nach nun hat
auch deutschland entschieden südafrika
ist virusvarianten gebiet ab heute nacht
dürfen von dort nur noch deutschen
staatsbürger eingeflogen werden sie
müssen sich hier 14 tage in quarantäne
begeben unabhängig vom impfstatus
noch weiß man nicht viel über die neue
virusvariante doch mit dem ersten fall
in belgien hat sie heute nachmittag
europa erreicht und einen möglichen
brandbeschleuniger will in der vierten
welle niemand riskieren
reden wir über den möglichen
brandbeschleuniger mit thorsten leer
professor für klinische pharmazie an der
universität der saarland ist sehr guten
abend nach saarbrücken einen
wunderschönen guten abend herr professor
lehr eine neue virusvariante die
experten und politiker besorgt nach
allem was sie bisher darüber wissen was
unterscheidet die von den bisher
bekannten varianten
ja also sehr viel ist noch nicht bekannt
aber was wissen ist dass diese neue
variante sehr viele mutationen im genom
zeigt also auch deutlich mehr als die
bisherigen varianten und vieles deutet
darauf hin dass das neue virus zum ein
ansteckender sein könnte und darüber
hinaus aber auch die immunantwort
beeinflussen könnte und zu einer
verringerten im monat wird sorgt das
bedeutet aber nicht dass games genesene
komplette dort raus sind aber wir müssen
jetzt wirklich sehr wachsam sein und
vorbereitet und auch
forschungsergebnisse abwarten die gerade
produziert werden das will auch die
europäische union seien die eu länder
haben heute entschieden alle
passagierflüge aus insgesamt sieben
ländern im südlichen afrika auszusetzen
für bundesbürger die aus südafrika
zurückkehren auch für geimpfte übrigens
zu gelten dann 14 tage quarantäne
er kann es denn aus ihrer sicht so
gelingen die variante zumindest außer
landes zu halten
ja das war sicherlich wünschenswert den
ausbruch dürfte damit maximal ein
bisschen verschieben anstatt ihn zu
verhindern die frage wird natürlich am
ende sein ob es sich wirklich gegen
delta durchsetzen kann das wissen wir
auch noch nicht aber sollte so sein ich
glaube ich nicht dass diese
quarantänemaßnahmen viel bringen sie
sind aber trotzdem wichtig um jetzt zeit
zu gewinnen auch ohne diese variante
schießen die fallzahlen ja durch die
decke die intensivstation laufen voll
wie lässt sich denn die rollende vierte
welle jetzt überhaupt noch aus
expertensicht zu abbremsen
der also unserer meinung nach ist es so
dass 2g und 3g plus nicht ausreichen
wird um diese welle jetzt wirklich zu
brechen das sehen wir an vielen
bundesländern schon wo es eigentlich
führt dass das reicht nicht aus wir
müssen unserer meinung nach eine starke
kontakt beschränkung machen sowohl im
öffentlichen als auch im privaten
bereich letztendlich ist kommt das einem
lockdown gleich und in der zwischenzeit
müssen wir boostern und impfen das wären
die wege seien wie wir aus dieser hölle
herauskommen und auch eine mögliche
fünfte verhindern schließt das einen
möglichen zumindest kurzen teil lockdown
auch für geimpfte ein
ja also unserer ansicht nach wären teil
doch dauernd ein kurzer heftiger locker
und sicherlich genau das richtige um
dieses infektionsgeschehen abzubremsen
vor allem auch unter dem blick dass wir
jetzt diese mögliche neue variante
bekommen weil das genau der richtige weg
um die situation wieder unter kontrolle
zu bekommen ein ruf aus saarbrücken der
zumindest in berlin offensichtlich hier
noch nicht angekommen ist so professor
lehr danke für dieses gespräch und größe
ins saarland ich danke ihnen
ja es ist wie ein wahr gewordener
albtraum oder nicht nur für diejenigen
die einmal mehr ihren alltag um
organisieren müssen schlimm ist es für
händler die wieder um ihre existenz
fürchten noch schlimmer für ärzte die
entscheiden müssen wenn sie in zukunft
noch versorgen können und wen nicht aber
das schlimmste ist und wir alle müssen
es uns von eingestehen der albtraum wäre
vermeidbar gewesen
das war unser zdf spezial ab viertel vor
acht beantwortet zdf heute live mit
experten weitere fragen zur neuen virus
variante zu sehen in der zdf- heute- app
und natürlich auf unseren social media
kanälen hier im programm geht es weiter
mit betis diagnose tschüss und auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]